bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de ski mag nous recevons
aujourd'hui jean michel fourgous
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines mais tout de suite
faisons le point en images sur le
vaccinodromes quais ouverts
souvenez-vous en janvier 2021
c'est super et une très bonne
organisation
et avec des gens sympas quand même
le vélodrome maintenant il ya une image
ancrée dans le territoire ça c'est inné
c'est une évidence eu des gens qui nous
en parle dans nos cabinets qui nous
disent voilà j'ai été vacciné au
vélodrome qu'est ce qu'elle veut
l'organisation bravo tout cela
[Musique]
chaque jour on s'adapte le point fort de
notre vaccinodromes c'est sa modularité
ici nous avons installé jusqu'à 46 boxe
dans sa configuration maximale c'est au
total plus de 1000 personnes différentes
qui ont oeuvré qui ont travaillé pendant
un an par rotation et bien sûr
il ya une certaine fierté ce qui était
très intéressant c'est d'avoir d'avoir
d'avoir été utile à la population au
moment où c'était nécessaire en plus il
ya eu une vraie cohérence dans
l'ensemble des relations qui sont
établis entre l'ensemble des médecins
qui se connaissaient que par courrier
interposé ou de téléphone s'étaient
jamais rencontrés dont il ya eu vraiment
une émulation très très important et
puis il ya eu le côtoiement aussi à
l'équipe nationale administrative qui a
été comme très très riche des
infirmières qu'on avait l'habitude de
côtoyer sous des angles différents donc
c'était non seulement c'était de la
fierté mais ça a été aussi une aventure
humaine
[Musique]
bonjour jean michel fourgous nous venons
de voir le premier sujet sur le bilan du
vaccinodromes c'est devenu un lieu
emblématique alors à l'échelle du
territoire mais aussi nationale oui
c'est devenu une fierté bien sûr pour
tout le territoire de 50 et des yvelines
même au niveau international puisque on
a parlé après dans tous les pays du
monde c'était un peu le la référence
française qui était montré les chaînes
de télévisions mondiales
dont bien sûr les échos et on écrit on
était de fait impressionnant mais aussi
pour les entreprises qui voyait que 50
avec un mobilisés pour eux aussi
donc les meilleurs moyens ils ont vu je
rappelle il y avait tout ici est un
restaurant pour les 1000 personnes qui
travaillaient en rotation et un ami
hôpital une pharmacie pour me parler les
vaccins
un service de sécurité surtout quand il
ya eu la taxe sur les contenus avec 6 mo
de rom donc des moyens quand même
importants qui ont été déployés
les boks ça a été ici 2000 mètres carrés
aménagé qui ont compris jusqu'à ce 46
boxe comment est ce que vous avez fait
pour être autant réactif parce que il ya
quand même beaucoup d'adaptation à faire
alors il y avait des jauges après il est
12 de rappel il ya une zone de dépistage
aussi qui a été créée ici en janvier
2022 comment on arrive à un tel résultat
en fait parce que des équipes aient été
il avait des objectifs de s'adapter sans
cesse qu'il faut remonter à 4 milles par
jour qu'elle fond on descendait à 1000
vous imaginez un peu d'adaptation il
faut
quand on avait les seniors c'est 17 et
bien sûr différente quand on a mis les
jantes un peu handicapé par un an il
fallait de doute moyen d'autres
organisations à chaque fois les enfants
chaque fois fallait s'adapter à des
cibles différentes
un soir c'est ptet on a même fait des
nocturnes pour les enseignants un autre
jour c'était pour les commerçants à nos
jours c'est pour nos entreprises à
chaque fois ce vélodrome s'est adapté
merveilleusement avec des équipes quand
même très entraînés aujourd'hui en plus
il m'a s'il ya une autre pandémie se ce
drame est considérée comme une réponse
puissante en cas de nouvelles pandémies
oui justement on est ici dans un
vélodrome alors comment ça s'est passé
la cohabitation entre les vaccinés et
des cyclistes en finale très bien parce
que on a continué à négocier avec eux
pour qu'ils puissent continuer à tourner
à s entraîner
c'était au début bien sûr leur piquer
leurs lots de romain mais ils ont quand
même compris l' urgence la gravité de la
situation envoyer tout le monde s'est
adapté d'ailleurs dans les moments
gravité vous voyez des moments de
solidarité extraordinaire des gens qui
ont travaillé ans tous ensemble lors
qu'ils n'avaient jamais travaillé on a
mélangé les dd discipline c'était très
plus dire et pluridisciplinaire pluri
acteurs et tout s'est très bien passé
parce que parce qu'ils étaient il relevé
un défi hors normes les camps quand vous
mettez objectifs élevés exceptionnel
vous avez des comportements exceptionnel
on l'a vraiment vu dans cette opération
qui a duré quand même 12 mois et
justement le hell vaccinodromes ils ont
fermé ou c'est resté tout le temps vers
donc c'est là c'est tout le temps ouvert
mais avec des modes différents qu'ils
font là réduit sur le sur un petit
centre qui est au fond quelquefois on
appris que la moitié ont partagé avec
d'autres activités et quelquefois en
prenez tout quand on était autour de
4000 on prenait tout donc à chaque fois
l'adaptation des équipes ont fait un
travail extraordinaire de toujours
s'adapter puis aussi de faire attention
à l'argent qu'on dépense et parce que
tout ça il souhaitait très coûteux on a
près d'un quart de million d'habitants
donc bien sûr faire ça dans des délais
extrêmement rapides
puis fallait s'adapter aussi aux
variations au début on avait passé deux
ans n'est moins de vaccins connaît les
dispositifs qui piquait des très
puissants y en avait pas assez de
vaccins bon à chaque fois fallait
s'adapter on échangeait avec des petits
centres aussi quand il en avait trop de
avec sa nounou aussi dignement on avait
trop là on échangeait à guilin travail
2-2 une synergie dans les yvelines
puisqu'on a on a bien sûr aider de
toutes les villes environnantes n'a pas
réservé uniquement aux saint-quentinois
parce qu'on disait attendez c'est pas
normal oui donc la solidarité la joue
aussi pour aider toutes les autres
petites communes qui avait pas les mêmes
moyens à l'organisation ici permettait
bien sûr d'aider tout le nom dans le
département en parlant de synergies
journée sur ce que vous dites ici on a
faim on était accueilli plus de 400
mille personnes c'est énorme c'est
considérable et du coup ça a permis le
lancement d'une étude épidémiologique
d'envergure sur tout le territoire saint
quentinois
je vous propose qu'on car peut-être que
ce deuxième sujet et puis après on en
reparle ça vous va jean michel fourré
bien en hiver
[Musique]
saint quentin en yvelines a décidé de
lancer une étude va permettre d'étudier
l'état de santé de la population de
saint quentin cette étude est fait en
partenariat direct avec l'ufr de santé
de l'université de versailles saint
quentin est une start-up hajime donc
issus du tissu économique local de
aj mais à la base nous on a déjà une
plateforme qui permet de mener des
études auprès des adhérents
d'associations de passion et sa plate
forme là on s'est rendu compte qu'on
pouvait la mettre à disposition de saint
quentin en yvelines pour mener cette
étude épidémiologique tout est anonyme
si quelqu'un ne souhaite pas répondre il
ne répond pas chacune des réponses qui
va nous être apportée chacun des
questionnaires complétés sera un pas en
avant vers la connaissance fine de cet
état de santé et donc une meilleure
compréhension et une meilleure réponse
aux besoins de santé de la population
c'est un questionnaire 360° sur la santé
si on se rend compte qu'il ya un
problème d'activité physique par exemple
on donne la possibilité aux décideurs
politiques locaux de voir par exemple
qu' il y a une sous activité physique et
donc de développer cette activité
physique cette étude va également nous
permettre de mieux décrire l'accès aux
soins de la population saint-quentinoise
et si il ressort de nos résultats que
cet accès est peut-être pas aussi facile
ou pas aussi simple qu'on peut
l'imaginer ça ça ne peut amener à
réfléchir et donc à essayer de trouver
des solutions pour permettre de
nouvelles installations pour permettre
un accès aux soins plus facile est de
répondre au mieux aux besoins locaux
[Musique]
jean michel fourgous on espère que la
crise est derrière nous mais si elle
venait alors du coup ce vaccinodromes
que va-t-il devenir ce vélodrome ce
vaccin semble que vont-ils devenir eh
bien on va le faire mais c'est une bonne
nouvelle c'est à dire que jamais sur les
gens sont excédés mois le ranger mais le
rangement doit permettre bien sûr de
comme ils le disent de réarmer cet outil
puissant si demain on est confronté à
une nouvelle pandémie ce qui n'est pas
exclu personne ne souhaite j'espère que
ce sera pas le cas je veux dire
qu'aujourd'hui on sait qu' il faut
surtout un gros centre comme ça doit
être prêt à rouvrir on sait travailler
tous ensemble c'est rare d'avoir vu un
tel rassemblement
pluridisciplinaire de gens vraiment de
bonne volonté qui ont travaillé avec
avec les tripes bien sûr et leurs
compétences mais on sent qu'il ya une
émotion pendant un an de sauver autant
de gens de gérer une crise d'une telle
violence bien sûr c'est un moment
affectif et émotionnel
bien sûr thérapeutique mais mais très
fort et quand on voit le regard de nos
seniors notamment c'était difficile
quand on était vraiment en danger et ça
ça a été tout le monde a été extrêmement
impressionnés par cela on peut dire que
les saint quentinois et le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines sort grandi de
cette crise ils le disent eux-mêmes ils
se sentent ils sont contents de voir que
ils sont protégés ici parce que il ya
cet outil maintenant qui est mobilisable
à tout moment merci beaucoup jean michel
fourgous avoir répondu à ma question
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis à très
bientôt pour un prochain numéro de ski
mag
[Musique]